6 25 on your wednesday morning not to be
confused with the most accurate eight
news now eight day weather forecast the
regional transportation commission and
the nevada department of transportation
have come up with their seven day
memorial day travel outlook
this graphic is mainly for anyone
planning on heading to southern
california on i-15 noting that the first
few days of the holiday weekend should
be okay once we get to sunday though the
rtc is predicting that some folks will
be cutting the holiday shore to head
back south early meaning drivers should
expect some backups on the 15 at prim
throughout the day
but sunday that's expected to be a piece
of holiday cake compared to possible 10
mile or longer delays on memorial day
monday
it's believed that some vacationers
taking that into account may spend the
holiday here in southern nevada which is
expected to lead to more slowdowns to
socal on tuesday
with wednesday bringing less congestion
on the 15 south
and to provide a little driving relief
here in town ndot says there will not be
any weekend work on the major road
projects we've come to know and love the
centennial bowl the speedway bowl as
well as the big squeeze on the 95 515
buckle up drive carefully please put
down the phone so i'm driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com